walking to this video a new 15 minute
game playing d bendy been our winter
deep inner winter okay d 4 okay let's
see i can i can go away for I'm
transposed to two possible the pills or
the modern defense but I'd like to play
bit differently here stay within the
Queen phone openings probably will get
an old Indian or maybe Kings Indian if
he decides to go for g6 he doesn't okay
yeah well Bishop g4 I go or g3 okay yeah
this is an interesting position type
here I need to be aware of black playing
a possible e 6 and d5 after which my
default porn might be a slight issue
what I'm doing to avoid that is to just
push it and this also means that
long-term a plan for white is to play
against the e75 it the pawn only seven
is now a bit hindered by d5 he will
probably play g6 so hard to imagine how
black can play this without g6 otherwise
you cannot get your your Bishop
developed I mean you cannot play you
five here IE 6 i'll just take play
Bishop age three and e6 is terribly weak
so one g6 looks normal maybe you can on
taking ng6 something along these lines
or take rook c8 gen then g6 but probably
I would play g6 yeah maybe after the
capture this is this is something that
you can of course do first
but it's a it's not clear that the
capture on d5 is always necessary one
aha hmm yeah well okay if I don't
believe he will play B 5v5 would we can
see six enormously maybe he's afraid of
Bishop b5 or something like that okay
the question is where to put the bishop
on g2 on F 1 2 G 2 R 2 e 2 or h3 many
possible positions h3 can be a really
good square because it prevents in any
porn move forever and it put the bishop
on this diagonal towards the c8 square
where blacks look is may be operating in
the future on the other hand if you play
the bishop on there to h3 it does not
provide any cover of the d5 pawn like
with Bishop g2 one possible f4 I do that
anyway it looks like an interesting
approach it's not the other I mean
Bishop g2 is also not bad at all
hmm yeah that's a strange move really if
I go a form he needs to just retreat you
cannot go to see four lights a fog well
no he can go there I mean between a for
this be five but i take p 5 so yeah then
therefore is just good I mean you cannot
go to g6 I mean if you go to g6 how are
you ever going to move your f8 bishop
you just need to retreat now night c for
Queen a forecheck b5 night XP 585 coin
b5 check 97 Quincy for em this is just
winning yeah so he needs to need to
return okay and now I have one therefore
move basically
Jim okay he now probably would play g6
no he simply refuses to play the moves
that I'm if I think he will play okay
and yeah i'm not sure what this is doing
running maybe maybe just developed
should be 3m
he goes Knight b6 this might be a point
of the Queen move Knight b6 queen bee
three was what I was trying to say now
Bishop deform and effect threatens
Bishop g7 hmm yeah almost I its strong
anyway let's let's play that not think
too much about it if he goes Bishop g7
now I can yeah I could take d 7 I mean
he needs to take what the king then
which is not nice but as I just have
rookie one this is much simpler now we
cannot cancel due to Bishop d7 yeah we
cannot cast Bishop e7 as nonsense he
said legs it's simple as that e seven
hangs oh I can't take it now I was
thinking maybe I was at first thinking
to take here I'm not sure if it if this
is better or not exchanging all those
things maybe it's probably it's um it's
very it's hard to say which bad word
what is better both them very very
advantageous
now these seven is just a and if we move
to the night I mean okay let's be seven
and where should the night go I mean not
be six mmm yeah yeah this runs right
into before fork it's not possible yet
but close maybe just a three here where
does the Queen go it can go to da them I
wonder maybe it was even better to take
this seventh first mean maybe twin da
turn
it's of course an excellent position I'm
not not complaining here just not sure
ever maybe add something better I can
take c5 and Chang p7 winning a second
porn but I really don't want to get into
opposite Catholic Bishops even though
it's certainly not the draw candle
opposite colored bishops position yeah
okay let's not be too sophisticated
about that if he goes queen d 8 I just
returned to where III maybe yeah III and
it's it's okay
I have the ponent a completely
dominating position but maybe it was
still easier to to play this Bishop d7
for tactical reasons because i get to d4
with the Queen quickly I can show that
afterwards it's of course a choice
between mother between many are various
good positions it's not like one is good
one is bad need to try to find the
optimum came to drive the night back and
b6 is also giving me on c6 welcome a
welcome target
yeah rook rook to c 6 would be nice but
not not according to the chess rewards
Roxy six hmm
here how to how to improve him
check it said it's very good for white
of course okay but how to how to really
make progress really something to see 6m
but if i move the night you can even
take d5 you habitat for this is just a
bad position um maybe yeah come on let's
do that let's do that if he takes d5 he
can't do that it's it's just tasted
terrible position yeah this is also
possible but i get i get i get play
against the deep on if he takes d5 yeah
this is this was quickly played my
general idea with all this is to retreat
the bishop play 94 to c6 and if it takes
i play rook t3 and get this pressure
against the deep on I don't mind to
return the pond
Bishop takes the same really was
stronger it looked a bit weird to me
this is why I didn't play it but um yeah
afterwards you know better hindsight is
always twenty-twenty yeah he sees gained
a bit of activity which was not really a
necessary thing to allow I'm still going
for 94 to see 694 yeah I guess I don't
see any problem with this really you
cannot enter with the Queen for example
yeah this one but I thought knight c6
where does the Queen go not sure
going to wear d7
hmm Jeff a touch of their interesting I
wonder ever should take this night but
Sir yeah it's slightly annoying piece
but maybe just retreat not sure if i
take the Queen can take that's not not
very nice
yeah that is so that's everything that
no that is not so clear I mean certainly
it's not terrible for me but it's not
it's not like an easy win takes Queen g7
is even some activity I don't know
really the ideas if he takes rook chicks
I'm immediately attacking the e4 night
+ f5 would be a concession I can just
take it then everything else fails maybe
I should go a four for us down now this
is better than a for a4 a5 get rid of
the target I came might play Knight be
too cautious just not be too quick about
all that yeah relief might be too that's
a myth
hmm ok so let's see maybe bishop yeah I
like that one actually Bishop p.m.
checking him now know if he takes a
three I can play queen bee three and he
needs to retreat and I take on safari
this is this is ok I need to get rid of
those nights of course them they're
really am really a past year allow it
far too much counter play him far too
much but soon really shouldn't this
really shouldn't have happened jump
right back to f6 and this is a weakness
maybe ok let's let's allow oopsie 6
prepare book c6 here
I'm just keeping b6 under fire I really
like to any to get rid of this night Sam
this is this is really annoying Luke
twin d3m the always feels like I'm about
to run into some some silly frog
hmm can I not just take now or not and
why can I not take look here for at the
end I foot knight c6 one looked III
where I can take I can take this is of
course a really good trade for me Bishop
and Bishop an idea me are much stronger
than a look of course he's got those
weaknesses g 6 a-6 and so on that i can
easily exploit my king is also
completely safe yeah
I wonder about the best way to play
maybe rookie three even getting one
block off yeah I can get the route i can
get the bishop to to f3 here push-up d5
rock t5 bishop f3s winning a whole rook
and here
not sure what's the most precise now
that's not bad for meand just let's just
play that keeping the ball and then
tending just rook rook c6 to get the
deep own as a winning pawn
the am night to be seven we are probably
better to to prepare that even a bit
more roop c6 yeah come on play play
technically just keeping things as
simple as possible if he attacks a3 like
rock d3i take a6 rock a three-book p6
taking be five it's the beep on then I
can regroup like that p 7 was also good
but no reason to not take the pawn
hmm just just grip
just grab everything let's see d 6pm
probably d6 Bishop c6
no I just need to take the rook here to
force the porn hmm i don't have the good
discover checker they are probably i
don't have have have a good one
yeah i also have they and be porn so I
don't need to force the depot keep on
through am directly and ending b5 a4 a5
and so on okay check
black resigns yeah I allowed allowed far
too much counter play let's look at look
at this again I didn't want to take on
these seven simply because it always
looks a bit weird to take a somewhat
passive looking Bishop with a good as a
big a somewhat passive looking night
with a good bishop but it's it's
probably even simpler like that this is
probably the easiest way to play because
if you look at this I can I can take b7
now without any problems or I have this
move which is also very strong it pretty
it's ready for and 94 and he must play
Quincy five basically and this this is
completely lost so easy I even then the
game now the TM I mean it's a it's a
fantastic position but around here I i
started to to play some maneuvers that
were really a bit unsuccessful the 94
idea where the computer always gives me
a big edge but it feels like I could
have done better yeah I'm just checking
if the computer find something to punish
my play but it always gives a big edge
yeah okay then maybe it was okay but I I
did I didn't like to have those two
nights around it always feels some bit
tricky yeah he couldn't he could take
here but he must return the poor now for
a good position so here and now i have
rooks e6 and it's just invasion
it still suffers from all those
weaknesses plus it's upon addition to
that yeah this basically gives gives up
entirely you must retreat and try to
somehow defenders it's it's not nice but
you can of course try to hang on and
hope for for mistake then the whole
opening concept here it slightly
slightly suspicious anyway this this
type of structures I guess pretty good
for white but he lost a couple of moves
this is really just losing a temple and
here you can you can debate if if I even
played in the best possible way ah the
computer gives a good line here check
this is this is this is of course a
tactical line but a good line haha yeah
you need to play more concretely
sometimes now what does black you know
the the problem is let's let look at
this few tweets I go here look somewhere
and then move like that if black is
completely busted I just pray he cannot
Castle this is the point the King has
already moved and that can just play a
rookie one and strengthen the position
this is just a disaster very strong 94
okay thanks for watching